foreign
dragon is in countdown Falcon 9 is in
startup
Dragon SpaceX go for launch
[Music]
thank you
are looking live at launch complex 39a
at Kennedy Space Center in just over 20
minutes this Falcon 9 rocket will lift
off carrying the 28th Commercial
resupply Services Mission from both NASA
and SpaceX to the International Space
Station
good morning and welcome to live
coverage of the crs-28 launch I'm NASA's
Jasmine Hopkins fueling of the Falcon 9
began about 15 minutes ago and we're
counting down to an instantaneous launch
at 11 47 a.m eastern time this Mission
will deliver about seven thousand pounds
of science supplies and equipment to the
space station and these missions help
NASA and our partners continue research
to better our life right here on Earth
and help us as we explore deep space
let's go now to SpaceX headquarters in
Hawthorne California where Zachary
Lupine is standing by to tell us more
about the vehicle supporting today's
Mission Zach
thanks Jasmine hello everyone my name is
Zachary Lupine and I'm an avionics
reliability engineer here at SpaceX and
it's great to be covering today's
mission in partnership with NASA
on your screen right now is a live view
of spacex's two-stage Falcon 9 rocket
with our Dragon spacecraft at the very
top dragon is one of the few vehicles
that can deliver significant cargo to
the space station and the only vehicle
that can deliver cargo from it and today
dragon has visited the station 37 times
and transported 280 thousand pounds of
cargo back and forth from the orbiting
Laboratory
below dragon is our Falcon 9 vehicle
which is actually two rockets in one the
lower part also the largest part of the
rocket is called the first stage it has
nine Merlin 1D engines which accelerate
the vehicle through the Earth's
atmosphere and into various orbits in
space
the top of the first stage is the black
inner stage and above that is the Falcon
9 second stage now the two stages will
separate about two and a half minutes
into flight and then the second stage
will ignite its single Merlin vacuum
engine or m-back engine which is the
10th engine on the rocket to carry
Dragon to its desired orbit
now during today's Mission you will
notice a shorter nozzle attached to our
second stage we are flying a shorter
nozzle when we don't need as much
performance to get payloads to their
final destination
now for those of you following along
today Mark spacex's 38th launch this
year Fourth Dragon flight in 2023 and
237th Mission overall
now Falcon 9 and dragon were both
designed with reflight in mind and the
vehicle Hardware is built to support
multiple missions with minimal
refurbishment
today's dragon is flying for its fourth
time and also Mark spacex's 20th reuse
of the vehicle
and the Falcon 9 first stage is flying
for its fifth time and we plan to
recover and fly both the vehicle and the
spacecraft again in the future
so far we've reflowned 170 first stages
including both Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy
and we're planning to recover this
booster on our drone ship a shortfall of
Gravitas which is currently stationed
off the coast of Florida in the Atlantic
Ocean and if successful this will Mark
the 198th recovery of an orbital class
rocket
now as the clock ticks closer to t0
Let's head over to NASA's Megan cruise
at Cape Canaveral to talk about today's
weather Megan thank you Zach and good
morning everyone welcome into Hangar AE
at nearby Cape Canaveral space force
station this is where I can monitor the
launch team as they take us through
today's countdown so so far hearing a
lot of good things over the Nets the
vehicle is healthy the team working no
issues the range is green meaning our
path from here to the International
Space Station is clear and safe and the
weather which has been the issue all
weekend forcing the team to stand down
Saturday and Sunday attempts today we
are 80 percent go you can see those
watch items on the bottom left of your
screen launch weather officer arlena
Moses will be monitoring a few showers
she expects to move into the area during
launch and I know some of you out there
you might be thinking it seems a little
windy out here but those winds are well
below any concerns for launch and as for
the weather around the booster recovery
area yesterday uh yesterday high seas
kept us from launching but today check
out this live look from spacex's drone
ship out in the Atlantic conditions are
still a little rough out there but
better than yesterday hence again that
80 percent go for a launch in just about
17 minutes
so right now SpaceX is fueling Falcon 9
rp1 or rocket grade kerosene load is
complete super chilled liquid oxygen is
being loaded into the first and second
stage you see those white clouds
completely normal that's some of the
liquid oxygen venting off SpaceX vents
off some of that locks to maintain the
right pressure in the tanks and those
clouds form when the liquid oxygen makes
contact with Florida's humid air
our instantaneous launch opportunity
today 11 47 and zero seconds eastern
time if we want to dock with the
International Space Station on Tuesday
June 6th for more on that let's head
over to Shaniqua vraine inside NASA's
Mission Control Center
thanks Megan and welcome to the
International Space Station flight
control room I am Shaniqua Marine live
at the Johnson Space Center here in
Houston Texas the team of flight
controllers at Mission Control Houston
today is being led by flight director
Scott Stover teams here in Mission
Control will really jump into action
tomorrow night into early Tuesday
morning as cargo Dragon approaches the
International Space Station there are
currently seven crew members living and
working aboard the station Expedition 69
consists of NASA astronaut Frank Rubio
Dimitri Patel of Ross Cosmos Sultan
anayadi from the United Arab Emirates
Woody hoberg and Stephen Bowen of NASA
Andre fed yayev and Commander Sergey
prokopiev of Ross Cosmos
as cargo Dragon approaches the
International Space Station and the
morning hours of June 6 NASA astronauts
Frank Rubio and Woody hober will be
monitoring the arrival from the
station's cupola cargo Dragon will
remain attached to the International
Space Station
it's seen at the Port of the harmony
module for about one month being one of
two dragons joining crew Dragon Endeavor
people are being packed up with critical
science and supplies that will Splash
down off the coast of Florida
for that science to be analyzed back
here on Earth everything is still a go
from the mission control center here in
Houston and we're looking forward to
welcoming another dragon to the National
Space Station so for now we'll head back
out to Kennedy Jasmine
thank you Shaniqua now we are about T
minus 14 minutes and Counting from
liftoff of crs-28 so let's talk about
the science new experiments will soon
arrive on the space station thunderstorm
observation equipment could improve
research on Earth's climate and weather
and astronauts will be growing a second
generation of plant seeds in space to
see if Gene changes transfer to Future
generations and those are just some of
the experiments joining the hundreds of
ongoing investigations already aboard
the orbiting lab this Mission will also
increase power supply on the station
delivering the third set of roll out
solar arrays also known as irosas after
being installed on upcoming spacewalks
the arrays will roll out into position
boosting power on the station by up to
30 percent
now across the country NASA and our
partners are making small steps and
giant leaps in preparation for the
Artemis II crude Mission around the moon
so let's take a look at our Artemis Moon
minute
all five major structures of the space
launch system Rockets core stage have
now been fully integrated at the michoud
assembly facility in Louisiana the
Indian section is the most complex and
intricate part of the core stage that
powers the Artemis missions to the Moon
rs-25 engine testing is underway at
stennis Space Center near Bay St Louis
Mississippi
this test is part of a 12 test series
that will certify the new design for
crude Artemis missions
the engine ran for its full planned 720
seconds the longest duration to date
at Kennedy Space Center in Florida
technicians have been testing the solar
array wings for the Artemis 2 service
module Orion will have four solar Wings
drawing in 11 kilowatts of power from
the Sun
some of the avionics for Artemis 2 have
already been to space technicians finish
cleaning and removing avionics on the
Artemis 1 Crew module which will be used
on the Orion capsule for Artemis 2 in
[Music]
now we are at T minus 12 minutes and
Counting from the liftoff of the 28th
Commercial resupply Services Mission
from both NASA and SpaceX to the
International Space Station let's bring
back Zach now to tell us more about
dragon's flight history Zach
thanks Jasmine for those of you
following along you'll know that it's
already been a very busy year and couple
of weeks for Dragon vehicles at the
International Space Station
crs-28 Mark spacex's fourth dragon
mission of 2023 following the launches
of crew 6 crs-27 and ax2
the dragon spacecraft supporting today's
Mission will be joining crew 6 and
dragon Endeavor which have been on
station since March so in order to make
room for ax2 and crs-28 at the harmony
Zenith port on the ISS the four members
of cruise 6 underwent a port relocation
on May 6th and put another way a dragon
move parking spots to make room for the
incoming dragons
a few weeks later on Sunday May 21st
dragon and the crew of ax2 lifted off
from historic launch complex 39a at
NASA's Kennedy Space Center and arrived
at station about 15 and a half hours
later and this is dragon's fastest
launch to docking time for a human
spaceflight mission
after eight days of living and
conducting research on the space station
Dragon freedom undocked from the
orbiting laboratory and returned the ax2
crew back to planet Earth off the coast
of Florida at 11 04 PM Eastern on
Tuesday May 30th and this made room for
the dragon vehicle supporting today's
mission
from the beginning Dragon was designed
to fly cargo and humans to and from
space and since dragons first visit to
the space station in May 2012 we've come
a long way in that time as I mentioned
earlier dragon has visited the ISS 37
times and nine of those missions carried
crew in fact the first time Dragon flew
people was just about three years ago
with SpaceX and NASA's demo 2 mission to
the space station
NASA astronauts Bob benkin and Doug
Hurley took the first flight on Dragon
on May 30th 2020 returning human space
flight capabilities to the United States
for the first time since the space
shuttle retired in 2011.
the launch of demo 2 also marked the
first time in history that a commercial
company successfully took astronauts to
orbit
and since then SpaceX has launched a
total of 10 human space flight missions
to space and to help enable greater
flexibility for future Dragon missions
SpaceX is preparing our neighboring pad
space launch complex 40 at Cape
Canaveral space force station in Florida
to support both cargo and crew missions
as we fly more and more people to and
from space human space flight becomes
more accessible and creates more
opportunities for Humanity to become a
space-bearing civilization
and now I'll turn it back to Jasmine at
KSC to take a look at one of the
payloads flying on today's Mission
Jasmine thank you Zach one experiment on
crs-28 could be used to predict your
risk for certain diseases aging and how
our bodies heal earlier this week I got
the chance to speak with the brains
behind genes in space 10.
joining us now is pristine on waha a
high school student from East Chapel
Hill North Carolina Welcome Christine
thanks for having me of course happy to
have you here so can you tell us a
little bit about how you're feeling a
high school student with your experiment
heading to the International Space
Station it's honestly a dream come true
this idea started off originally in my
head and now it's going to be a reality
pretty soon so I'm really excited of
course we love that excitement pristine
and we cannot wait to see your dreams
realized can you break down what is the
genes in space 10 experiment the
experiment involved telomeres and these
are the repetitive sequences that cap
the ends of our chromosomes on the earth
tone your is normally shortened as we
age but for astronauts in space they
actually appear to get longer and so
with that I developed an experiment to
see if that process could be linked to
the activity of stem cells now in the
development of that experiment something
really important was measuring telomere
length but it turns out that isn't
something that can really be done on the
ISS instead experiments involving DNA
link measurement need to be sent down to
earth and that costs time and resources
so with that the genes in space team
that I got thinking what if we developed
an experiment that could help address
that and so we developed an experiment
that allow astronauts and the Isis to
detect the fourfold difference in DNA
length and so with that it opens the
door up for more kinds of research to be
done on the ISS such as into genetic
monitoring because being in space makes
me more prone to genetic mutation so
that's something that can help with that
also opens the door up for more research
into tone years to be done and even
broader
Christine that is so exciting and your
experiment was chosen out of over 600
applications so what advice do you have
for students who are also interested in
this opportunity yeah I would just
encourage other students to just explore
their passions in space biology and
pursue it as best as you can that's what
I did and it led me to where I am here
exactly very excited to have you here
and tell me what are your plans after
high school I mean you've got some great
things on the horizon right yeah so in
the fall I'll be headed off to UNC
Chapel Hill I'm planning on studying
either biology or biochemistry and I'm
really excited to get more involved with
biological research in the future
especially space biology of course thank
you so much for joining us today
Christine thanks for having me
thanks again to pristine for speaking
with us and she is not the only student
experiment going up on CRS 28 stem
engagement is very important to us here
at Nasa for the future of the Artemis
generation
all right now we are just about seven
minutes and Counting and to lift off of
crs28 so let's bring back Megan here on
Florida Space Coast and Zach live at
SpaceX headquarters in Hawthorne
California to walk us through the final
moments of the countdown take it away
thanks Jasmine it's T-minus six minutes
and 50 seconds and the SpaceX team is
currently working no significant issues
and the vehicle is healthy weather is
currently 80 go and the range is ready
to support today's mission
at this point rocket propellant 1 or rp1
fuel is completely loaded on the second
stage and nearly complete on the first
stage liquid oxygen or locks loading is
currently underway on both stages and
will complete at the T minus two minutes
Mark to Launch
we're also loading helium gas into both
stages Falcon 9 uses helium as a
pressure to backfill the propellant
tanks as locks and rp1 are consumed by
the Merlin engines during Ascent helium
load began before the broadcast went
live and will continue to top off until
about a minute and a half before launch
and about 40 seconds ago SpaceX
performed the engine chill that's when
the team flowed a small amounts of the
super chilled liquid oxygen into the
Merlin engines turbo pumps they're
basically prepping the propulsion system
for the full flow of liquid oxygen by
doing this they avoid avoid a thermal
shock to the system ensuring engine
start let's go load is complete and you
heard that call out for stage one fuel
RP fuel load complete now Dragon also
began its startup sequence at T minus 35
minutes when it coordinated timing with
Falcon 9. the spacecraft is currently
undergoing vehicle health checks it will
enter terminal count at T minus five
minutes with the next big step just a
minute before liftoff when Dragon will
transition to internal power
now you may have noticed those white
clouds around the vehicle those are
completely normal they are chilled gas
above the Lox tank with lox tank liquid
surface that we vent overboard to
maintain pressure in the tank as needed
and when that gas comes out into contact
with the warm humid Florida Air the air
condenses into clouds and water
now
or power
[Music]
the transporter erector or te is used
for vehicle rollout and a route
propellants and electrical power to the
vehicle in preparation for launch and
once those clamp arms have fully opened
the te will then retract away from the
rocket in preparation for liftoff
we have a hot mic on the countdown that
all parties check your key panels
strongback lower has started
we should see those clamp arms opening
in about 15 seconds from now
those clamp arms are located just below
the trunk of the vehicle which is
beneath the dragon spacecraft
and there you can see those clamp arms
beginning to open around the booster
now in these last few minutes before t0
Falcon 9 is performing final hell checks
on its primary Communications avionics
and propulsion systems in preparation
for flight and we may hear callouts that
engines are sufficiently chilled as we
get a little closer to liftoff
clamp arm should be fully open and the
transporter erector that strong back is
going to recline away from the rocket
now you may have noticed in some of
these shots the Falcon 9 booster
supporting today's mission is covered in
quite a bit of soot and that is because
it previously supported NASA crew 5 GPS
3 space vehicle 6 inmar sat 6 F2 and one
starlink mission
and you can see that strong back slowly
reclining away from the vehicle stage
one lock load is complete
this launch will bring about 7 000
pounds of Hardware crew supplies and
science to the space station one
research project will study the effects
of space on human DNA another will study
the effects on plant DNA findings from
both could help us Advance things here
on Earth but also prepare us for future
farther missions into space
and dragon will be docked to the space
station for about a month before
returning home
now check out some of the second stage
thrust vector control actuators are now
underway this is often referred to as an
engine wiggle test this is when SpaceX
moves the thrust nozzle slightly to make
sure the guidance Hardware is ready for
flight
SpaceX will do the exact same test on
the first stage engines but that happens
just seconds before ignition
now dragon is also performing its final
health checks to make sure all of the
vehicle's primary systems are ready
International Space Station
call out that stage two locks loading is
complete that wraps up pellet loading
for both stages of the falcon 9.
and as I mentioned earlier you may have
seen those white clouds around the
vehicle ground gas what you see are the
chilled gas above the Lox tank liquid
surface that we vent overboard and when
that gas comes out in contact with the
warm Florida Air the air condenses into
clouds and water
now dragon is about to transition into
internal power also Falcon 9 computers
will then enter startup mode which is
when the Falcon 9 flight computers take
control of the countdown guiding the
rocket through the last seconds before
liftoff you should hear a call out about
startup shortly
Falcon 9 is in startup
dragon is in countdown
both stages are now pressurizing for
launch at T minus 45 seconds we'll hear
the SpaceX launch director verify go for
launch
go for lunch
there you go and at launched the
International Space Station will be
flying 260 miles over the North Atlantic
south of St John's Newfoundland
15 minutes 30 seconds
15 seconds
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3
two one ignition engine full power and
liftoff of crs-28 go falcon go dragon
liftoff of about 7 000 pounds of science
including a new pair of solo arrays
at t plus 40 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from historic
launch complex 39a in Florida
and we're now coming up on Max Q in
about 20 seconds from now and this is
the point of Maximum aerodynamic
pressure that the vehicle will go
through during its flight
or sonic traveling faster than speed of
sound
that's cute
and there you've heard the call out for
Max Q coming up next are three events
back to back the first of which is main
engine cutoff or Mikko and this is when
all nine Merlin 1D engines on first
stage shutdown
after those nine engines shut down the
first and second stages will separate
and this is also called out over the
Nets as stage separation
from there the second stage will ignite
its Merlin vacuum engine to boost Dragon
to low earth orbit during SES or second
engine start one and this whole sequence
takes about 15 seconds
should be expecting that call out for
main engine cut off in about 40 seconds
from now
some amazing views of our Falcon 9
vehicle as it takes our Dragon
spacecraft to orbit
and in just about 10 seconds we should
see that main engine cut off
Nico
age separation
in recognition
and there you heard those call-outs and
probably saw on your screen main engine
cutoff followed by stage separation and
then second engine start one
as I mentioned earlier we are flying an
mvac nozzle a shortened m-back nozzle on
our second stage
if you're just tuning in you're watching
a live webcast for the 28th commercial
resupply mission to the International
Space Station for NASA this is spacex's
38th mission for 2023 and the Fourth
Dragon flight to the International Space
Station this year
we lifted off from Kennedy Space
Center's historic launch complex 39a
just about three and a half minutes ago
now on your screen on the left side you
can see our Falcon 9 first stage which
is going to
descend back towards Earth and the
second stage on the right side of your
screen which is carrying the dragon
spacecraft
now as a reminder today's Michigan
flight for this Falcon 9 booster Falcon
9 booster which previously supported the
crew 5 gps3 space vehicle 6 in marsat 6
F2 and one starlink mission
in order to make its way back to our
drone ship a shortfall of Gravitas the
Falcon 9 first stage has two more Burns
to execute the first is the entry burn
where three of the Merlin engines will
reignite
this helps slow the stage down as it
re-enters the upper part of the Earth's
atmosphere
the entry burn is followed by The
Landing burn and this is a single engine
burn that brings the vehicle speed down
rapidly in order to land on the Drone
ship
now occasionally with the Falcon 9 first
stage on the left side of your screen
you may see some small white Puffs and
those are nitrogen gas bursts that are
used for attitude control
you can also see there on your screen a
pair of the Hypersonic grid fins
falconized is equipped with four of
these grid fins which are comprised of
titanium and they are positioned near
the top of the first stage once in the
atmosphere stage one is only using the
grid fins for steering as it makes its
return to Earth and these grid fins
Orient the rocket during re-entry and
guide the rocket during its descent
now the Falcon 9 first stage has nine
Merlin 1D engines and and each engine
generates about 192 000 pounds of thrust
on the second stage is the mbac engine
which has a slightly wider nozzle
and that uh and the vacuum engine
generates about 203 000 pounds of thrust
next major Milestone is going to be the
first stage entry burn which will take
place just over a minute from now
there you can see an amazing view of our
stage 2 with its shortened mvac nozzle
the Falcon 9 first stage which is not
currently on your screen has reached
apogee and is now beginning its descent
back towards Earth
the second stage is continuing to take
our Dragon spacecraft to orbit
we should see that first stage entry
burn begin in about 15 seconds from now
on the left side of your screen
stage one entry second stage on the
right side of your screen
and there's that call out for stage one
entry burn startup on the left side of
your screen the second stage is
continuing to take our Dragon spacecraft
to orbit
now again the entry burn is the first of
two Burns that the Falcon 9 booster
performs before landing on our drone
ship
stage one entry burn shutdown
and there's that confirmation of stage
one entry burn shutdown
as we get closer to First Stage Landing
it's good to note that the Falcon 9
first stage is equipped with four
Landing lengths made of state-of-the-art
carbon fiber with aluminum honeycomb
these Landing lanes are placed
symmetrically around the base of the
rocket and deployed just prior to
Landing
and if successful
this Landing will Mark the 198th time
that we've recovered a first stage
booster including both Falcon 9 and
Falcon heavy missions
we are about 25 seconds away from that
Landing burn beginning
Sonic
now as the rocket descends through the
Earth's atmosphere this really puts
deceleration into perspective in the
span of less than a minute will have
reduced from twice the speed of a jet
all the way down to zero as the rocket
lands
and as Falcon lands we may also hear a
call out that the second engine will
shut off around the same time
Landing like to play
Adrian Landing is burning and and there
you have it the Falcon 9 first stage
that supported today's Mission has
landed for its fifth time having
previously supported crew 5 gps3 space
vehicle 6 in marsat 6f2 and a starlink
mission today's Landing also marks the
198th successful Landing for an orbital
class rocket you may have also heard
confirmation of good orbit acquisition
signal to Finland
at t plus 9 minutes and 30 seconds into
the mission we are coming up on the last
major task for stage two commanding
separation of dragon a couple minutes
from now and we expect to have video of
Dragon separation from the top of the
second stage which looks into the trunk
crs-28 will be joining the crew 6
vehicle currently on orbit I could also
we'll be back to having two dragon
spacecraft science research crew
supplies and vehicle Hardware to the
orbital laboratory and its crew
to date SpaceX has sent and brought back
over 280 000 pounds of crew and cargo to
and from the space station
and we should be seeing Dragon
separation about a minute and a half
from now
as a reminder this is the fourth flight
for this Dragon capsule having
previously supported crs-21 crs-23 and
crs-25 to the space station
today's flight also marks the 20th reuse
of a dragon vehicle overall
now dragon has 16 Draco thrusters on
board each with the capability to
deliver 90 pounds of force there are
four pairs of three thrusters spaced
evenly around the capsule as well as
four forward bulkhead thrusters
underneath the nose cone
now notably today's Dragon does not have
super Draco thrusters seats or life
support systems as it's not carrying
crew and this saves on weight and space
and also allows for a faster
refurbishment time
while initial designs of dragon carried
solar arrays extended outward from the
trunk the cylindrical structure located
directly behind the Dragon capsule
the current dragon has these arrays
fixed directly to the trunk and you may
see at some point both a light and the
dark side of the trunk and that dark
side is actually those solar panels
while the light side is a radiator to
help cool the spacecraft
and speaking of solar panels you can see
on your screen right now the solar
panels that we will install on the
International Space Station
once the Dragon capsule reaches the ISS
it will be able to autonomously dock
using its navigation sensors Center Line
camera and light detection and ranging
or lidar equipment
and there you can see on your screen
dragons separating from the second stage
well that's going to do it for me here
in Hawthorne have your next Milestone
coming up is the is the dragon nose cone
opening sequence
and navigational sensors
and I'll toss it over to Shaniqua in
Houston to talk us through it Shaniqua
thanks Zach everything is still going
well back here in Mission Control
Houston right after a dragon separated
it began a series of automatic checkouts
including small firings of the Draco
maneuvering thrusters the next Milestone
is no scone deploy the nose cone
protects that docking hardware and
Rendezvous and tracking elements on top
of dragon during a set the nose cone
deploy uncovers the four forward
bulkhead thrusters which Dragon will use
for its major burn maneuvers
and we do have confirmation that that
nose cone deploy sequence has begun
again major burn Maneuvers will be
dragging nose cone to play cuff uncovers
those uh major Hardware
it will also uncover Dragon Eyes that
Rendezvous and tracking Hardware that
allows Dragon to know where it is in
space and how to find the space station
once opened the nose cone will stay in
that position until the very end of its
Mission closing prior to re-entry to
provide some of that additional
protection to the same Hardware during
re-entry
it does take about five minutes for a
nose cone to open we are looking for 12
hooks two sets of six that will open
here and once open we will see the nose
cone deploy
again that sequence has begun
and we'll be waiting to hear once all 12
hooks are open
and we will see movement of the nose
cone as all 12 hooks open after nose
cone deploy is Cargo Dragon will be
safely on its way to their actual Space
Station
if you're just joining us NASA and
spacex's 28th commercial resupply
Mission launched from pad 39a at the
Kennedy Space Center in Florida at 10 47
a.m Central Time 11 47 a.m eastern time
and is currently in orbit we're standing
by now for nose cone deploy
and dragon is filled with over 7000
pounds of cargo and supplies including a
variety of science investigations
hardware and Fresh Foods for the crew on
station
some of those Fresh Foods that will be
delivered include apples grapefruits
oranges cherry tomatoes and blueberries
Dragon will dock to the Zenith or
space-facing side of the harmony module
just recently freed up by Dragon Freedom
which brought up the Axiom 2 crew
the Axiom 2 crew aboard the SpaceX
Dragon Freedom spacecraft safely slashed
down off the coast of Florida at 1004 PM
Central Time 1104 PM Eastern on May 30th
2023.
the crew's return officially concluded
the second all-private astronaut mission
to the International Space Station
Axiom 2 commander and retired NASA
astronaut Peggy Whitson ended her
eight-day Mission with a new record of
675 days in space
the most of any American or woman
and while we're discussing records NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio will end his
mission this fall breaking a record of
his own Rubio will return to Earth
aboard a Russian soyuz spacecraft no
earlier than September 27th and in his
State aboard the orbiting laboratory
having logged a total of at least 371
days in orbit
that tour of Duty will beat the previous
record of 355 days said by NASA
astronaut Mark vandehe in 2022.
joining Rubio on station are six other
crew members living and working aboard
the International Space Station
Expedition 69 also includes Dimitri
patelan from Russ Cosmos sotan Araya
from the United Arab Emirates
Woody hoberg and Stephen Bowen of NASA
Andre fredierev and Commander Sergey
prokopia of Ross Cosmos
All crew members are awake and after
enjoying a midday meal some are headed
to exercise while others are headed to
do some spacewalk procedure reviews
NASA astronauts Stephen Bowen and Woody
hoberg are prepping for a June 9th
spacewalk to install one of two new
rollout solar arrays on the space
station starboard side trust structure
this cargo resupply will bring up two
new rollout solar arrays packed inside
its unpressurized trunk
acquisition a signaling